to be in that regard justin fields was a
game changer in college obviously dealt
with an offense that didn't maximize his
skill set last year he gets luke gets he
is his offensive coordinator coming from
working in that green bay offense you've
got byron pringle eq st brown and we've
heard all about bayless jones their
rookie draft pick and the relationship
he's already building with fields so if
you take that combined with some of the
sack potential on the other side on
defense they could be an interesting one
in that long shot range all right if we
gave you a thousand dollars and you had
to put it on one of two win totals to go
over look at the jets we'll look at both
new york teams so look at the jets they
are at five and a half right now that
line has not moved since the draft or
the giants who are at a little bit of a
beefier seven who would you take
oh god you guys are really sick for this
one yeah i know but we are but uh i'll
say i probably air with the giants on
this one now brian dabo is certainly
exciting we saw what he did maximizing
the skill set of one quarterback that
people had questions about early on and
so maybe that's a helpful antidote for
daniel jones who hasn't quite put it
together yet but i also look at what we
know about the schedule coming out here
so the nfc east is going to draw the nfc
north and the afc south on this one so
the nfc north and a bit of flux and we
know the afc south outside of the now
tom brady full buccaneers there's some
winds to be had in there the af the nfc
east excuse me as a division i think is
a lot more up for grabs than what the
jets are dealing with in the afc east
where you've got the super bowl champion
favorites in your division you've got
the patriots that are always the thorn
in your side miami made major moves this
off season and they're going to draw the
nfc north and the afc north which is a
super tough one so jets roster still a
little bit away even though i think
there's a lot of players to be excited
about about that team all right give us
a non-quarterback that we should be
considering placing an mvp vet on right
now no surprise derek henry has the best
odds at 50 to 1. traditionally a
quarterback roll but is there anybody
you like outside of the quarterbacks
yeah i think i'd go back to the jonathan
taylor well and we know he got a lot of
that mvp buzz during last year running
back for the colts but i think bringing
matt ryan over this is going to be a
more stable offense they drafted alec
pierce as one of their top picks the
wide receiver out of cincinnati so
another big body guy for that receiving
core a defense that i think really up
front you know for them a defense last
year what they were able to do i know
they're losing mad eberflus but i think
there's going to be so much stability
and a better offense around him that
that could open up more opportunities
for jonathan taylor and i think they'll
be making some serious playoff buzz
which we know that sell is a big part of
a player outside of the quarterback
ranks having the potential to crack an
award like this so we've seen a crazy
influx of talent in the afc this
offseason with all of the trades that
have impacted that conference and it
leaves the nfc uh a little bit more wide
open compared to the afc is there a team
that you think people are sleeping on in
the nfc that could ultimately steal the
conference
yeah you know we talked about this
division already i'll say the
philadelphia eagles we know they were a
lot of the draft noise there the aj
brown trade bringing him over from
tennessee they got two of my favorite
players in the draft both out of georgia
indeed tackle jordan davis and then his
teammate nicoby dean who felt like the
steal of the draft at linebacker for so
many people i don't think jalen hurts is
necessarily the long-term answer there
still i think he ends up being a
high-end backup but
he understands how to work in this
offense now him and nick ciriani worked
out a lot of the kinks last year and if
that offensive line is healthy if you've
still got miles sanders there in the
backfield you've got an offense that
developed a pretty clear identity and if
that defense can do a better job of
getting to the quarterback i think
there's at least potential there in a
conference that's certainly the weaker
of the two i like it teams that can run
the ball always got a shot once they get
in and the eagles they know how to run
the football all right mike before we
let you go where can the people check
out your podcast for draftkings
yeah gojo uh it is five days a week
monday through friday available on apple
podcast spotify google podcast wherever
you hear things we are going to meet you
there and we look forward to talking
with you all right great stuff from mike
golic jr thanks so much for the time
thanks for having me really appreciate
it
my man mike golick jr and connor looking
good there connor rogers talking nfl
futures but i want to talk hoodies and i
want to talk 250
in dk dollars because that's what i want
to give away right now connor i am in
the comments looking for takes
uh people are asking how do they get
their hoodies how are they going to get
their jerseys how they're going to get
their dk dollars do not worry we will
hit you up on messenger on the app so
check your messages on the app you will
see something from br betting or
bleacher report we will hit you uh i'm
in the comments though
i got
jojo473454 says jets long shot is more
likely to me shout out to you jojo you
are walking away with a hoodie um
i see i also see ajuan ajuwon says
detroit lions are the king of the north
i think he means that they're going to
win
the nfc north wow that is huge huge take
connor i mean i'll give it to him i like
i like the confidence i like i don't
know if i like to take but i like the
confidence so just because of the
confidence you are walking away with 250
dk dollars i have one more hoodie to
give away connor one more hoodie to give
away
and it's going
to jplev 221
oh sorry about that 2-2-1-0 and guess
what connor he's showing love to your
new york jets he says the jets are going
to go over they're going to go easy over
they're going to get seven wins
so therefore i'm giving him a hoodie
just for you connor that's just for you
brother
i appreciate you greg and he should uh
he should get in on that odds boost and
get it at plus 110 on draftkings instead
of minus 140. all right we have a lot
more to give away including a 250
a month bankroll for the football season
so let's keep it moving and talk odds to
win the conferences right here all right
here are the odds to win the nfc
championship no surprise there tom
brady's bucks at the top super bowl
champs not the favorites right here
they've lost some big time names like
von miller andrew whitworth retired
packers of aaron rodgers always going to
be in the mix there plus 500 greg's
niners at plus 750 then it gets a little
wonky here you got dallas you got
arizona as long shots philadelphia has
longer shots and then the vikings at
plus 2200 all right all right
so greg is there anything you like here
and what do we need from the audience
right now to get involved in a little
conference championship futures action
first and foremost i need to everybody
to get in the comments and tell us who
you think is winning the nfc i'm giving
away hoodies and a jersey connor i'm
gonna get right to it
you guys are probably gonna be like greg
you're a nighter fan greg why are you
picking the nut no i do not want to hear
it this team was in the nfc championship
last year
with jimmy garoppolo as their
quarterback yes jimmy garoppolo was the
quarterback and this team got to the nfc
championship i think that they're going
to take a step up and quarterback by
putting trey lance out there
with the same team almost the same team
is coming back for the 49ers i don't
really know too many uh losses that the
49ers took that that are eye-opening as
far as in free agency but this pretty
much is the same team coming back with
the better quarterback connor i can see
them taking the nfc
this year i mean look at the odds
they're plus 75 i like those odds over
green bay over the books over the rams
we all know about super bowl hangovers
but i'm rocking with the niners plus 750
give me the niners
we're improving on quarterback and we
have kyle shanahan as the coach you
mentioned earlier what kyle shanahan
does to an offense i mean we're going to
see what he's going to do to an offense
with an actual quarterback that can
throw the ball
connor which way are you leaning
it's all about trey lance if for those
niners greg it's all about trey lance
see if he could be an upgrade over jimmy
g
i'm gonna glean a little chalk here i'm
gonna go with the bucks and i just i
have a rule that i don't really pick
against tom brady uh especially in these
scenarios where he couldn't go out a
loser he came back for one this feels
like one last big run before he gets all
that tv money from fox so plus 330 i
still think those odds are fine it's not
crazy value you're not throwing the
house on this but you throw a little bit
on it at plus 3 30. brady it feels like
all the pieces are there they got chris
godwin back healthy they got mike evans
gronk is going to come back after otas
he just doesn't feel like dealing with
otas or and i'd rather enjoy his spring
so
i'm gonna lean with the bucks i know
it's a chalky pick but i think brady's
got one more super bowl running him i
don't know if he's got a super bowl
title greg but he's got one more super
bowl run so i know the comments are
jumping and i know you have an nfl
jersey to give away to them
i am in the comments i'm in the comments
and they are all over me picking the
niners
uh i also see some fly eagles five shout
out to you d dukes 21 you are walking
away with the hoodie i'm also giving
away a a
a jersey here i see uh
i see rb139 says tampa they still got
brady don't adam
shout out to you rb139 you are walking
away with a hoodie uh quincy
quincy says
why change jimmy dude wins
he wins
but you can always improve if there's an
upgrade out there why not improve also
it's been it's been reports i i think
the niners might be trading jimmy
garoppolo who knows we'll see how that
plans out uh but
you you always want to improve in this
league you always want to get better and
i feel like the niners can get better
with trey lance at quarterback uh shout
out to you though you are walking away
with the jersey that i'm giving out in
this segment connor
i think it's time to talk some afc
championship now though brother
yeah this is where it gets a little more
dicey right this is where all of the big
moves were made this offseason we saw
russell wilson come over from the nfc to
the afc we saw matt ryan do the same
this afc is gonna be a bloodbath and
let's take a look at the odds and the
odds are gonna show you that obvious the
bill is at the top big time favorites
plus 330 they're looking for revenge
against those chiefs that are the
runner-ups here at plus 550. you've got
the chargers a huge rise at plus 800.
they didn't make the playoffs last year
in their plus 800 the broncos after
acquiring russ plus 8.50 the bengals who
were in the super bowl last year who won
the afc last year disrespected at plus
1100 the colts like i said matt ryan
there now plus 1200. baltimore's made a
ton of great moves especially in the
draft and then tennessee all the way
down the board they were the afc's
number one seed last year uh but they've
lost a lot of big time pieces that have
them down the board at plus 1500. so
greg
you uh you took a little bit of a
a risk with your nfc pick you didn't
start at the top of the odds board what
do you like with the afc that seems to
be
much much tighter
connor and the afc i am eating chalk
give me the chalk cause i will eat it
buffalo bills i like them to win the afc
this year they have a bad taste in their
mouth what happened in the playoffs last
year i think they're gonna come back
with the vengeance they also added some
reinforcements connor some good
reinforcements my man von miller oj
howard to help out that offense and
jamison crotter in the slot that can
help free up uh my man stefan diggs for
josh allen so uh i like what the buffalo
bills did in the off season they have
that bad taste in their mouth and i
think that they're gonna come this
season with the vengeance and uh
i can see them going to the super bowl
connor talk to me talk to the people
which way are you leaning as far as in
the afc
well i gotta say greg you've been on the
bills before they were the chalk pick at
the top so nobody can hate on you for
riding with them again here nobody can
hate on you for that i'm gonna roll with
the chiefs right now i i look at this
and just go man i think everybody is
overreacting to them losing tyreek hill
there's no doubt there's not a player in
the nfl like him with his kind of speed
but i think patrick mahomes is now that
he's ever had the training wheels on but
he's ready to know what it's like
without that number one wide out and
he'll spread the ball around you still
have travis kelsey there i think this
team with their offensive lines can be
able to run the ball and i think the
defense is going to be a lot better with
the draft picks and the signings that
they've made whether it's justin reed uh
once again they drafted a lot of defense
got trent mcduffie george carloftus
they've done a lot of really nice things
to
diversify and round out this roster then
rather it being a little bit top heavy
for once so i like the cheaps to come
out of the afc but i do think it's going
to be close i i hope this is the matchup
right here i hope we get bill's chiefs
again
this time obviously in the afc
championship with a little bit of a rule
change where are the comments going
right now i think this is going to be
one of the
the most up in the air ones i think
everybody's going to have a different
opinion and i will say i like the colts
as a dark horse pick here if i had to
get one way off the board i would take
the colts as the dark horse big
connor i'm in the comments right now but
before i get into the comments i do want
to say if we get that match up again
chiefs bails connor you know what we're
doing hammering the over but i'm in this
come in the comments i'm in the comments
i see breed winners breed winner says
bills are stacked
vonn abouts the push for defensive
player of the year denver will make a
splash though okay shout out to you
breed winners you are walking away
actually breed winners i love that take
so i'm giving you a jersey now giving
away some hoodies aiden malloy 34 says
bronco is going to surprise everyone
wow broncos are going to surprise
everyone shout out to you aiden you are
walking away with a hoodie um bagel and
locks bagel and locks he was in the
comments earlier hating but guess what
connor you know what we do to negative
vibes bad vibes we turn bad vibes into
good vibes so uh
you are walking away bagel unlocks you
are walking away with a hoodie but let
me give his take it's take set coats all
day they got matt ryan got a good coach
got a running game out there they might
can do something uh in indianapolis but
connor that that's it for this segment
that that's it that's enough hoodies to
give away and i gave away a jersey shout
out to everybody uh continue continue to
keep commenting because we got more and
more giveaways
to give away
all right and continue to stay on
draftkings for more conference odds in
the meantime we had a chance to catch up
with the director of the draftkings
sportsbook johnny avello to talk 2022
futures look at this market take a look
at our conversation with johnny
all right now really excited to welcome
in a familiar face a legend of the
draftkings sportsbook johnny avello
johnny it's future season for the nfl
how are we doing right now good connor
doing great thank you we're aways from
the season starting but uh no reason not
to get excited it's that time of year
where we get a little bit too excited
and get ahead of ourselves so i got to
ask you
what are the most popular bets right now
coming in for mvp are there any
surprising names you've seen in the mix
so far
well when you look at the category
there's one position that dominates and
that's
the first 16 possible selections are all
quarterbacks tom brady's at 10 to 1 uh
he's getting the most money so far
followed closely by josh allen 7-1
they've been the two most popular
choices but
herbert 10-1 jackson 25-1 borough 12-1
they're all getting some attention
now you asked about a surprising name
that would be jalen hurts at 18 to 1
taking about five percent of the money
and with the acquisition of aj brown
devante uh smith back for his sophomore
season i think the bettors are expecting
some bigger things there yeah the birds
fans usually show out too five percent
of the market that's a pretty good
number for jalen hurts considering 18 to
one so uh looking now that we're after
the draft here what is the most popular
offensive rookie of the year bet to date
right now
uh when i would be bruce hall uh nine to
one we'll step right into that jet
backfield and receive significant
playing time uh he's the top choice that
the other rookie that's seen quite a bit
of play in this market is christian
watson uh he's eight to one after
opening up 15 and one now
characters took him early in the second
round if he can catch the ball
half as well as devonta adams he might
be right in the mix for this award
that's a massive movement and uh that's
the name i was not expecting you to say
so with that being said speaking of
massive movements of lines what line has
moved the most as a result of all this
offseason wagering so far well kind of
we put up all those international games
for the entire season
and the one we've seen the most movement
on is the seahawks versus the bucks
on november 13 in the lions arena now
i'm not talking about raiders home
alliance stadium in las vegas now i'm
talking about the home of the european
football club the fire
unit team uh we opened tampa an eight
point favorite they are now up to nine
wow a full point movement and you and i
are having this conversation in may
football the football markets are truly
unbelievable and i am guilty as charged
all right what has been the most popular
new market this year
are you rolling out any new markets this
upcoming season we've seen draftkings
roll out new stuff every year it's been
a lot of fun to watch
we put up these markets called division
specials
and one division that's really popular
is the afc west you know that's due to
the division being just totally stacked
with russell wilson now bronco devonte
adams or raider and the chiefs and the
chargers both improving their teams
we're seeing this prop most regular
season passing yards between herbert
mahomes carr and wilson taking a bunch
of action uh herbert's now to six to
five favorite a couple other props out
there that involve that same division or
that are really trendy are will all four
teams make the playoffs 20 to one
uh on the s
and pick the exact order of finish in
the afc west
and those odds range from seven and a
half to one to thirty five to one
god so the bloodbath that you see west
is literally creating their own markets
at this point just when you thought they
couldn't be stopped johnny avello it is
always great to talk to you my friend
thanks so much you're welcome connor
johnny avello and my man connor rogers
connor that's three different outfit
changes in one show i think we got to
put odds on it is it three and a half is
it gonna go over three and a half or
under three and a half you guys let me
know in the comments my man connor
rogers is changing fits like no other on
this show but uh
i'm in the comments that's why i'm here
i'm in the comments because i'm here to
give away some hoodies and 250 dk
dollars and i see i see moneyline killer
moneyline killer says eagles and raiders
over eight love that take been seeing
that on my feed uh for the last several
day a couple days actually
so i like that shout out to you money
moneyline killer you are walking away
with the hoodie also giving out a jersey
here
and i'm looking for a good take and i
see r blount zero or blount zero
never any love for the coats plus 1200
is great value hey colts fans you guys
are getting some love i'm sending you
250 dk dollars are blunt zero
the coats may not be getting love from
the media but guess what greg is sending
you love i'm sending you 250 dk dollars
connor
let's get to the nitty gritty let's get
to the juicy part of the show let's talk
mvps brother
yeah it's time to get serious greg let's
talk mvp since the year 2000 only four
players have won the nfl mvp
that were not quarterbacks this is a
quarterback award anything else is a
long shot there are only quarterbacks on
this short list of potential mvps the
odds board is dominated by the signal
callers josh allen and patrick mahomes
the only ones coming in at under plus a
thousand and then a wide open board of
herbert brady rogers
borough russell wilson and matthew
stafford all right greg what do you like
here on this one
you see that man
four from the top his name is uh tom
brady plus 1 000
i think my guy is going to go out with a
bang connor last year i just i'll just
read some of his numbers uh 5
316 passing yards
43
touchdowns thrown my man had a passer
rating of 102.1
this was this is this man's 40 plus
connor he's 40 plus and he was actually
considering retiring after having a year
like that i think he's gonna come back
and do it even better
uh they might have a deep run into the
playoffs too they might have a deep run
into the playoffs but they might
meet up with a team from uh the west
coast and
might uh
take tom brady's uh championship
aspirations away but i do like tom brady
to win mvp talk to me talk to you connor
i mean talk to the people
which way are you leaning with this one
i like that pick greg i think brady's
got four games to stat pad in his own
division against the falcons and the
panthers as well and he can just get by
his kryptonite that is the saints he's
gonna be
right at the top of that board by season
ten so i'm you took some value you
didn't take one of the top guys that
were under a thousand i'm doing the same
thing i'm going to take joe burrow here
i really like uh our conversation
earlier on the show how joe burrow could
spread the ball around he's got you marc
chase he's got t higgins he's got tyler
board tyler boyd they spent a lot of
money on this offensive line and free
agency and i think it's going to pay
dividends and i think it could pay
dividends for those betting on joe
burrow at plus 1200 for the mvp greg
where are the comments going right now
it's a pretty wide open board for this
one
connor let me see what the comments is
talking about i'm in the comment the
comments right now
seeing what they're talking about okay
zach young says herbie herbie over 45
touchdowns this year okay i can see that
i can possibly see that i also see uh
adam spicer
plus 2 000 on derek henry moore
run heavy now that brown is gone
derek henry in the tennessee titans and
connor
i'm giving away i think a jersey here i
think i'm giving away a jersey here i
got joe burrow for mvp rm buckman79 he
is rocking with your play connor so
shout out to you aaron buckman you are
walking away with a jersey
of your choice
all right visit draftkings for more
player awards futures including rookie
of the year both offensive and defensive
rookie of the year we asked you in the
app to drop your locks though
for receiving yards title you see cooper
cup there at the top plus 700 he was the
offensive player of the year last year
so no surprise to see him there justin
jefferson an absolute target monster
right behind him at plus 800 then this
board opens up greg you got kelsey there
you got jamar chase there uh you have
devonte adams of course tyree kill
stefan diggs tied at plus 1400 and then
devo samuel if he wasn't also a running
back in a sense he'd probably be even
higher on this board as well so
vr betting's own natalie bodie is going
to join us to go over some of our
favorite takes and we're going to give
away 250 dk dollars to our favorite
commenters not commenter commenter so
you want to stick around and get in on
the action here let's welcome natalie to
the show right now what's up natalie do
you have any favorite futures you're
looking at for this off season here
what's up guys you know connor i live in
atlanta so at some point i've got a
route for the hometown team maybe the
falcons and over five wins it's it plus
money
unsure my confidence level there but
let's talk some receiving yards you guys
here are three of my favorite comments
from the people of course and the first
one is actually from tommy he's at icky
shuffle in our app who says that he
likes devonta adams with those odds at
plus 1200 of course is what he's
referring to what do you guys think of
adams at this spot
i love it this would be my pick on that
board as well if i wasn't looking to go
much much deeper i think the odds are
very fair at plus 1200 you're getting
some value i think he's walking into a
situation that uh he's going to be a
target monster the familiarity there
already with derek carr when they played
together at college together carr
obviously a huge proponent of this trade
hunter renfro's there darren waller's
there they're nice players but they're
not going to be the focal point of this
offense that devonte adams is and they
just traded another wide receiver while
we've been on the air and brian edwards
so that is even more targets on the
plate for davonte adams i love this big
hey i'm right there behind you connor i
like this pic a lot as well you
mentioned devontae playing with his
former college teammate so the chemistry
is going to be there
but uh to lead the league i
i don't know if i'm gonna
love this play
i think i like somebody down down on the
list a little bit more my man from the
buffalo bill stefan dix but uh i do like
this one i do like this one a lot
natalie
plus 1200 is juicy i'm with you guys i
like that number especially with the
addams and car duo teaming back up and
we can't forget they won the mountain
west championship at fresno state so i'm
not sleeping on that mountain west duo
but what do you guys think about this
next comment we've gotta potentially buy
a source let's be honest at cincy dude
is his name he says chase duh so jamar
chase at plus 1200 is that as obvious as
this guy thinks what you got connor
i think the duh is a little rich but i
respect it from the username cincy dude
repping his own team i love jamar chase
he's the best wide receiver i've ever
evaluated coming out of the nfl draft i
just think with the bengals it's
actually more of a compliment to their
team that they can spread the ball
around the easier than a lot of these
other guys on the board t higgins is
quietly maybe one of the best number
twos in the nfl right now they have
tyler boyd as a number three i think
they'll throw to joe mixon and burrows a
guy that when you go back all the way to
his breakout season at lsu in 2019 he
likes to keep everybody happy he likes
to keep all of his targets fed he will
spread the football around and the book
is out on jamar chase he's one of the
best wide receivers in the entire nfl
already and not even 23 years old right
now so teams are going to bracket him
he's going to see double teams teams are
gonna say somebody else beat us
that's okay for the bengals they'll be
able to do that to win games it's not
good for betting on jamarche's futures
i'm right there behind you connor i
don't think this one is a duh bet this
is one isn't a lot for me uh this is the
second year we know in the nfl usually
guys are less productive in the second
year than they were in the first year uh
adjustments will be made adjustments
will be made for jamar chase so i just
don't know if i can bet on him to lead
the league in receiving you mentioned it
conor we know what my man joe burrow
likes to do he throws the ball 50 times
a game almost he's spreading that rock
around
uh so
i i just don't know if i'm willing to
bet jamar chase to have the most
receiving yards next year
looks like we're all in agreement there
i'm with you guys vero's got a lot of
targets i'd rather sprinkle my money
elsewhere let's go to this next comment
though our third comment from
at5018 he says if dak played a whole
game instead of the fourth quarter only
cd would have a shot he's of course
talking about cd lam at plus 1800 what
do we think
i like a dark horse pick i'll always uh
vote up for that i think though
the problem is kind of in play here
right well what dak are we going to get
it's not just dag it's the entire dallas
offense a offensive line that's been
reworked a little bit they're going to
be playing some younger players there uh
no amari cooper which might open up more
targets for cd lamb i know they drafted
jalen tolbert but now cd lamb is the
number one guy in that offense but it's
just a matter of how much attention is
he going to see from the defense as well
and how is he going to adjust to that cd
lamb has done a ton of damage from the
slot with cooper and gallop on the
outside now it's a little bit more on
his shoulder so
i like the value i'm not really the
biggest fan of the pick and i think 5.0
said it right here he's not even the
biggest fan of this pick because it's
hard to trust their first half offense
yeah yeah i love the value i don't know
if i'm picking this exactly uh
that i can see him having over 5 000
yards pass we know they like to pass the
ball down there in dallas but my thing
is is is he going to lock in on cd lam
he has a lot of weapons out there he has
a lot of weapons in dallas is he going
to lock in on cd lam to have him have
the most receiving yards this year i
just don't know if i'm willing to bet
that and like you said conor even
5.018 don't even know if he's going to
bet that because he doesn't have the
faith in deck so uh
this one this one's actually pretty
challenging for me to see cd lamb
winning or having the most receiving
yards in the nfl this year
with cooper gone they definitely need
him to step up i'm always hesitant to
depend on the cowboys really for
anything you guys but i'm from texas so
i can say that we're gonna move on
though and decide who wins that 250
in dk dollars
look i gotta give it to cincy dude
simply because his comment with the duh
in there in all caps i like confidence
and conviction so you sir are going home
with 250 dk dollars
i like it greg you are usually the man
giving away the dk dollars on this show
what is your response to that
yeah yeah because not only is natalie
giving away 250 dk dollars but i'm in
the comments right now i'm live in the
comments giving away 250 dk dollars and
i see j p l e v 2 2 1 0 says cup at plus
700 honestly is great
value so shout out to you you are
walking away with 250 dk dollars i just
want to say this natalie i matched it
250 bk dollars i also can give away 250
bk dollars here on the drop zone
of course you can greg of course you can
now happy to be here with you guys greg
glad you could one-up me there at the
end but awesome stuff youtube
natalie thanks so much for uh jumping on
the drop zone with us today thanks again
all right now it's time to talk super
bowl and give away our grand prize and
if you just jumped in with us that is a
250 a month bankroll for the entire nfl
season you're going to be sitting pretty
if you walk away with this one so super
bowl 57 is scheduled for february 12th
in arizona which team will be there to
hoist the lombardi trophy
let's take a look at the odds board
right now super bowl favorite buffalo
bills did not know i would say that in
my lifetime i like good for the bills
fans plus 650 there big expectations the
bucks plus 700 tom brady's last ride a
lot of people think kansas city and
green bay mahomes and rogers and uh the
rams the defending super bowl champs all
at plus a thousand and the chargers
getting in on the fun fred's niners
there as well plus 1600 and then the
broncos now led by russell wilson at
plus 1600 as well so greg first off i
want to know what you like on this board
or maybe off this board and how does
somebody win the grand prize of a 250
per month bankroll for the entire
football season
first i need everybody to get in the
comments i'm about to give away hoodies
jersey and
that 250
a month bankroll that connor is talking
about for the football season to one
lucky winner what i need you guys to do
is get in the comments and tell me your
lock to win the super bowl
now this one connor this one this one's
tough for me this one's tough because we
got the 49ers i told i chose them to win
the nfc and then we got the bills i
chose them to win the afc
you know how i feel about my 49ers but
i'm going to be real here we trey lance
is such a question mark
that i can't i cannot go right now and
bet on those 49ers even though those
odds are very
very juicy
it's just a question mark and i just
cannot make that commitment at this very
moment maybe in uh august i might be
able to commit after seeing some
preseason games but right now i just
cannot commit so therefore connor by
default by default
i'm rocking with the buffalo bills man i
think that they can get it done we talk
i already talked about it last year i
talked about it on the drop zone i
talked about the the the offensive
presence that they have the defense that
they have they brought in those
reinforcements i already mentioned them
but i'll mention them again my man von
miller o.j howard to play tied in as a
target with stefan dix also brought in
jameson crowder to fill in the slot they
have the running game singletary they
have what it takes conor it's just about
them putting it together
and can they do it this year right now
in may i think that they can i think
that they can do it so i'm rocking with
the buffalo bills connor which way are
you riding
for the championship
big expectations for the bills and
they've earned that great roster great
improvements in free agency in the draft
right there so i like that pick greg i'm
sticking with the afc as well i think an
afc team ends up winning the super bowl
this year as much as i like the bucks on
the nfc side looking at the chiefs here
i'm looking at the chiefs the chiefs
have somehow become a little bit of the
forgotten man there's a couple of things
number one i like a little bit of the
value here as well with the chiefs pick
you are getting some value by picking
them i think we're also starting to
forget just how great patrick mahomes is
you see the plus 1000 right there andy
reid not gonna be coaching forever i
think there's a little bit more urgency
there uh urgency this year they've made
a volume of moves instead of just
landing one big ticket star so i like
the chiefs here on the super bowl ticket
where are the comments going right now
we get a lot of chalk pics here greg are
they getting real down the board and
creative
my man adam spicer adam spicer said we
are sleeping on the vikings sleeping on
those vikings shout out to you all right
just because we're sleeping on the
vikings shout out to you adam spicer you
are walking away with the jersey go get
a vikings jersey why not uh moving on
moving on
rb139 says as much as i hate to say it
the browns if watson plays imagine that
team
with a quarterback gave us fiery emoji
shout out to you you're walking away
with a hoodie uh eric solis said the
bucks shout out to you zapdos zapdos
says the chargers plus 1500.
uh they're all over the place
comments is all over the place link 21
niners d gets it done over the bills in
the super bowl i mean i can see that
happening link uh so shout out to
everybody that i just mentioned you are
walking away with hoodies but connor
the comments are all over the place it's
early it is early comments all over the
place but i guess we'll just have to see
what happens
next year's football season
greg i think you still have a jersey to
give away or are we uh we moving on to
the grand prize here
i i still got a jersey if connor says i
have a jersey to give away i'm going to
give away a jersey i'm back into the
comments i'm back into the comments
and i see
jp
lev2210 says chargers are a dark horse
love the take
they did do a lot in the off season to
build that team up love their
quarterback justin herbert is a baller
he's a baller love the tech you are
walking away with a jersey
of your choice
all right you've given away the jersey
how are we picking the winner of the
grand prize vr betting bankroll here
greg
all right connor you all have been in
the comments dropping your super bowl
locks now we're gonna spin a will with
all 32 nfl teams whichever team it lands
on
i'm picking one random person who picked
that team to win the br betting bankroll
that's
250 dollars a month for the football
season
okay connor are you ready because i'm
feeling the itch to spin this wheel
brother
let's get to it let's spin the wheel
all right let's let's get to it three
two
one and the wheel starts spinning there
it is there it is let's see which team
it lands on connor will it be your jets
will it be my 49ers will it be
who i wonder who it will be and it's
looking like it's going to be
the browns wow
the browns connor the browns are the
winner uh how do you feel about that
how do you feel about the browns
connor talk to me how do you feel about
that
i mean trust the wheel i mean the browns
fans have been waiting for this for a
long time desean watson's in town
although
he might be dealing with the suspension
so their playoff hopes might be on how
jacoby brissette can keep them uh
treading water i
i don't know about this greg i
there's gonna be somebody in the
comments though i'm assuming from the
dog pound that's gonna be feeling really
really good about this and that grand
prize
yeah i mean let me uh
connor the wheel picked the browns i'm
dumbfounded at the will picked brown but
the wheel picked the brown so someone
who took the browns is walking away with
the br betting bankroll i'm going to get
in the comments
right now i'm giving away hoodies giving
away hoodies first and then i'm going to
uh
give
then i'm going to give away
that
250 a month so here we go i see the
saints k hogan two says saints
uh
shout out to you you walk away with
hoodie
ny718 says the
bills shout out to you you are walking
away with a hoodie uh one more hoodie
nino adam nino adam says the bears wow
hey i like that though it's a lot of a
lot a lot of uh
a lot of plus money if you're picking
the bears but connor
rb139
rb139 mention the browns
so shout out to you rb139
you are the winner of the be our betting
bank roll
so man run it up this football season
please run it up
man that's got to be feeling real real
good if you learned anything today
let it be that you don't have to wait
for football season to start to get in
on the action as you see giving away
bankroll giving away jerseys giving away
dk dollars get on draftkings and bet
your favorite futures and be sure to
take advantage of that jets odds boost
went from minus one wait connor wait
wait wait wait brother wait wait i'm
i'm so sorry i did not mean to cut you
off but before you already know before
we get out of here i gotta hook some
more people up with some hoodies so i'll
make it quick gm34 you're walking away
with a hoodie uh i got rb139 you just
won but why not you're if you don't have
a hoodie i'm giving you a hoodie i also
see link link 21 link 21 you were
walking away with 250 dk dollars and one
more one more connor i got
adam spicer i don't know if you got a
jersey but you are walking away with a
jersey of your choice conor apologies
brother but i had to do it i just i just
added it for the people
i'll never have a problem with it when
it's for the people alongside greg ivory
i'm connor rogers congrats to all our
winners don't worry vr betting is going
to dm you in the app and take care of
you and get you your prizes we will be
back in august to kick things off for
the 2022
nfl season see you then
[Music]
[Music]
you